mais les rangs de saint-just président
du groupe rassemblement national au
conseil régional d'ile-de-france bonsoir
et les rangs de saint-just merci avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors que
vous inspirent ces hommages en france à
la mémoire de cet american church of
floyd
écoutez j'ai dans ces manifestations il
ya certains certainement un certain
nombre de manifestants de de bonne foi
et nous nous nous rejetons évidemment
tour affichant tout antisémitisme
c'est clair mais si quand même gênant
c'est que elles sont à l'initiative de
la famille traoré est né alors cette
famille n'a pas l'air vraiment en fait
digne de monter ce manifestation
premièrement deuxièmement qu'est ce qui
s'est passé exactement dans la sphère de
adama temps ray on ne sait pas sauf
qu'on sait qu'il ya deux expertises
judiciaires qui met en cause peut être
totalement hors de cause et gendarmes
il faut savoir raison garder et ne pas
aller proclamer comme le font un certain
nombre d' excités qui sont dans serez
face à sion que les soutiennent que la
police française est raciste que la
france est un pays de racisme systémique
tout ça est entièrement fausses et
diffamatoires c'est scandaleux
nous sommes le pays peut être le moins
raciste du monde et la police française
et la police certainement la moins
raciste tout le monde
alors va les rendre saint-just
effectivement vous nous dit tiens il ya
deux expertises qui dédouane totalement
les forces de l'ordre il n'empêche une
troisième expertise indépendante cette
fois lancée par la famille traoré qui
justement incrimine cette fois ci les
forces de l'ordre vous comprenez tout de
même la colère de cette famille que vous
jugez que les relevés à digne de lancer
ces informations va ces manifestations
donc ces deux questions peut-être en une
mais voilà cette expertise et cette
famille quand même qui est en colère bon
supposons qu'ils aient cette troisième
expertise que l'on puisse la considérer
qu'elle n'ait pas été ordonnées
légèrement exécrable et le problème
supplémentaire dans des dossiers et dont
beaucoup dossiers de ce genre c'est la
lenteur et l'incapacité de la justice
je crois que le drame qui a affecté
adama traoré c'est de 2016 nous sommes
en 2020 que font les juges
et sinon toutes les affaires pareilles
alors en france la justice n'a aucun
moyen et des juges ne veulent pas
travailler en que s'ils ont peur ils ont
peur humeur de truies comme nos comme
nos politiques d'ailleurs comme ne se
casse à nice où ils sont tétanisés par
la peur de l'accusation de racisme ou de
discrimination
or il faut qu'ils fassent leur travail
et faut qu'ils fassent leur travail
8 une famille comme la famille traoré
que soit celle là avec ce qu'on peut en
penser ou d'autres familles de victimes
de maux de dos tu peux y arriver avec
les policiers c'est sûr peuvent être
très rapidement ni au courant de ce qui
se passe du bourde contre des
responsabilités et que la police la
justice fasse son travail
vous savez dans un grand nombre de
situations politiques sociales de notre
pays s'en va mal parce que le pouvoir
régalien la justice ne fait pas son
travail voilà et dans de nombreux cas ça
irait beaucoup mieux si elle le faisait
son travail
alors ce soir la république en marche à
travers un tweet a appelé à se
recueillir en la mémoire de zhangzhou
floyd a de son côté le miz de
l'intérieur indiqué qu'il n'y aurait pas
de sanction pour les manifestations non
autorisées on appelle aujourd'hui pas
plus de dix personnes sont autorisées
dans l'espace public en raison de la
crise sanitaire ça vous inspire quoi
cette indulgence de la part de
christophe castaner aussi castadère
tétanisés par la peur qu'elle se verrait
n'importe quoi on ne peut pas on ne peut
jamais cantonnée mise à terre abandonnée
l'état de droit et si on n'a pas droit
de manifester on ne manifeste pas
il ya une infraction qui s'appelle
participation à une manifestation
interdite et il faut faire passer les
enfants et ils soient jugés les
déportées soit condamnées mais au moins
qu'ils soient je sais que ministère
l'intérieur enfin son assemblée de faire
quelque chose
il ya aussi une cacophonie incroyable
sein du gouvernement
castaner avec son propos de 2 ce matin
ou dire je n'y ai plus le moindre
soupçon à gérer de racisme chez les
policiers entraînera une suspension
immédiate
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ne pas
suspendre les gens comme ça soupçons
avérés 5l il maintient incroyable alors
il ya castaner qui s'agenouille et
notamment aux sages ou que je vois en ce
qu'ils achètent la police et en même
temps il doit philippe qui dit ce soit
il faut beaucoup de respect à l'égard
des de la police aidée et des gendarmes
et des forces de l'ordre en france
oui ce gouvernement que fait ce
gouvernement ils sont encore une fois
tétanisés alors qu'il faut imputer
l'état de droit appliquer des règles
régaliennes et demander notamment dans
des drames comme la soirée parce que
quand même un homme est mort et il ya
des éléments qui ferait tout est de
l'origine de la main que la justice dise
rapidement que procurent les
instructions d'un chien 10 rapidement
ceux qui dans l'est et qu' il est un
tribunal qu'ils soient saisis hier votre
parti par la voix de jordan bardella
estimé que emmanuel macron et christophe
castaner lâcher la police et la
gendarmerie et que c'était leur rôle au
contraire de les soutenir c'est votre
analyse également
c'est extrêmement grave personne n'est
capable de mettre en cause et forces de
l'ordre dans la ferte de monsieur adama
traoré
premièrement deuxièmement nous avons une
police la police je le répète des forces
de l'anp point raciste il peut toujours
exister des incidents bien sinon qu'on
appelle des bavures quand on est en face
de bajur on les fait traiter encore une
fois très rapidement par la justice et
si le policier où les policiers sont
coupables à la moi je suis d'accord pour
lé que les sanctions soit absolument
exemplaire un semestre
pardonnez-moi mais la third adama traoré
qui aujourd'hui décline
l'invitation de la ministre de la
justice elle a bien fait parce que tout
simplement il ya une séparation des
pouvoirs ou au contraire elle aurait dû
y aller elle a bien fait enfin bon la
lnh en très intelligente et en même
temps très politique je c'est
complètement ridicule de la part de
madame belloubet risque d'avoir de la
part de même de nouvelles de qualité et
deuxièmement contre la constitution
entre la séparation des poids c'est pas
madame b to b qui doivent savoir
mademoiselle traoré ce sont des
instructions et le procureur de paris
pour lui dire voilà ce qu'il ya dans la
procédure et on vous promet on va aller
vite et qu'on va vite faire juger cette
affaire c'est ça qu'il faut faire vite
cette famille malgré ce qu'on peut en
penser tout cas à damas tremor merci les
rondes st juste d'avoir été avec nous
président du groupe rassemblement
national au conseil régional d'île de
france